If you were given the chance
at non-monogamy
in paradise,
what would you do?
I'm Scott Evans,
and I will be your guide
on a journey for love
unlike you’ve ever seen before.
For the next month,
four curious couples
will be given the unique opportunity
to turn that fantasy
into a reality.
I've never been on a date with three people.
You know what I’m saying?
Me either.
I'm bisexual
and he's more of a
don't-knock-it-til-you-try-sexual.
Yeah.
It is kind of like our first time
dating as a couple.
We make a good team.
Check!
Let's go!
Every few days,
they'll invite one of fourteen
open-minded singles
to throuple up with them in the resort.
We would like to invite...
Womp womp.
With a bed big enough for three.
Y'all alright in there?
They'll be helped along the way by an expert.
I’m going to test your threshold
on watching your partner
get intimate with your chosen third.
To get their poly on,
Man, I keep having these uncontrollable boners!
Can he say that?
Like can he-
Yes I can!
Can we get some lube, lube, lube?
Use your mouth.
That is an order.
Last night was a workout.
Last night was a ****ing workout, girl!
Will they commit to life as a three?
Will you be my girlfriend?
I just got chills.
The compatibility is off the charts so far.
Or will this experience reveal
that the throuple life
is not for them?
At the moment, I don’t see how sex works.
Jealousy relates to
a person detecting a threat.
I’ll see you two bonding without me
and it’s like...
Tension?
You can cut it with a ****ing knife.
**** is about to get real.
Have you done something alone with him?
What I’m saying is that
why wasn’t it a group decision?
I felt a connection, but you know it was more
towards me,
not you.
I'm tapped out.
Last night was just like a **** show.
Woah!